americans are constantly hearing about
problems with our criminal justice
system like racial profiling and prison
conditions but today we're going to talk
about people you don't usually hear a
lot about prosecutors prosecutors are
the people who represent the government
in court in other words they represent
us but what if they're not representing
all of us i'll explain in a segment
called how did we get here
tonight we're going to talk about
prosecutors you probably know them from
shows like law and order or the good
wife or fancy justice lady who can
really put off pull off a hat
okay i made up that last one or maybe
i'm here from the future to tell you
about your new favorite show starring
amber ruffin in a hat
prosecutors are so important they even
have their own signature sound
[Music]
you know it that's actually the noise
prosecutors make when they orgasm
scientific fact but here's the thing
that is also one of the whitest sounds
of all time because it turns out that as
of 2019 95 percent of prosecutors were
white and then 95 is so white it's like
i'd like to speak to the manager white
95 percent is front row seats at a billy
joel concert white
america's prosecutors are so white they
think el debarge is a giant mexican boat
and the racial disparity exists all over
the country but hey why does it matter
lots of things are super white and don't
really hurt anyone like living in
vermont or saying i'll be there in a
jiffy
how long is a jiffy white people i need
a number
so let's talk about why the race of
prosecutors matters in three parts first
arrests then charges and finally
sentencing we'll start with the rest now
i know what you're thinking aren't cops
the ones in charge of arresting people
well sort of see there's no point in
arresting someone if they're not going
to be charged with a crime and
prosecutors have basically absolute
power in deciding whether a person gets
criminally charged that's right
prosecutors have the ability to ruin
lives in a split second like plane
crashes or the cool ranch doritos locos
taco supreme combo at taco bell
but i'm still eating that mug
and there are times when prosecutors
choose not to press charges when they
clearly should for example police wanted
to arrest the three men who chased and
murdered ahmad arbury but the local d.a
jackie johnson wouldn't allow it then
the case was transferred to this
prosecutor who said there were no
grounds for arrest then they gave the
case to a third white prosecutor who
still didn't arrest anybody it wasn't
until cell phone video of the murder was
released that the state appointed this
woman to the job and she finally charged
ahmad arborist killers basically those
white prosecutors treated actual
murderers the same way you might treat a
dog who pooped on your living room rug
cover it up pretend it never happened
and hope that someone eventually comes
along and cleans it up for you
since then the three killers have been
convicted by two separate juries and as
for whether the prosecutor's office was
actually racist it is worth noting that
the first d.a actually refused to
prosecute the murderers because one of
them had worked with her in the
prosecutor's office that's right the man
who was just convicted of a federal hate
crime worked for decades in the office
of the district attorney so just like in
scream the call was coming from inside
the house
but arrests aren't the only place where
race plays a role because once you're in
custody prosecutors also get to decide
what crimes you're going to be charged
with and that can be biased as well
a harvard study found that da's charged
black suspects with crimes that carry
worse penalties they ask for higher bail
for black defendants they're less likely
to offer black people plea bargains and
they ask judges to sentence black
defendants to longer terms in prison
then every single possible way black
people face worse outcomes than white
people which is the opposite of what
happens during a line dance
i love it
and even if somehow you are fairly
arrested and charged racism can also
play a role in sentencing now i know you
think i'm going to give you a bunch of
stats about how judges and juries give
longer sentences to black people and
that's true but it's not the most
important thing because over 90 percent
of felony convictions are actually the
result of plea deals and the terms of
those deals are offered by you guessed
it the prosecutors
oh good for them they met someone
a recent new york city study showed that
black defendants were more likely than
whites to be offered plea deals that
included jail or prison time and it's
not just true in new york take these to
ohio women who are convicted of
embezzlement carla hopkins and debbie
bosworth now first yes debbie bosworth
sounds exactly like the name i would
make up for that white lady but it's
also her actual name
now carla stole 42 thousand dollars
while debbie on the other hand stole
almost a quarter of a million and carla
was sentenced to 18 months in prison
while debbie was given just 10 months
just kidding six just kidding zero she
was given zero prison time there are
these are two women in the same county
in the same court system who were
sentenced within one year of one another
i wonder what could have made the
difference
basically
think of making a fair plea deal like
singing along to a jimmy buffett song
anyone can do it but it's going to go a
whole lot better if you're white
it's not applicable to me and
margaritaville
is that jimmy buffett uh
i don't know that's fair you shouldn't
now
i know i spent all this time telling you
about problems with white prosecutors
and to be fair we don't know for sure
that black prosecutors would fix the
criminal justice system we only know
that in studies black judges showed less
of a bias against black defendants that
black cops are less likely to use force
and that juries with at least one black
member are less likely to convict a
black suspect does that mean that black
prosecutors will do a better job dealing
with racial disparities how the hell
would i know because here's the thing
there aren't enough of them to count but
we need to find out because the next
time i hear this
i only want to be thinking about one
thing
sweet
sweet lovemaking
this means how did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you